this is Warped Tour man Rob's got some
catching up another sort of big um dump
of well maybe not even exposition
because we don't learn that much but we
do get a lot more hints of things that
are probably to come um pretty much
they're they're going through the warp
and Steven accidentally sticks his head
out and he sees something else warping
and he's saying it's there it's there
doesn't anybody believe me it's there
it's there and we go through the whole
North by Northwest they where nobody
believes them and I I hate those stories
I hate stories where it's like no it's
really there and nobody believes the
person cuz it's just like you don't I
gotta come around they're gonna believe
him eventually at some point so that
stuff I didn't get into but I kind of
got it as well it's like you know when
garnet saves him she's like no you're a
gem too we should you know just didn't
mean to treat you as a gem we should
treat you seriously um and again serve
that interesting hostility that's
growing between them but they're still
it's not it's not super strong because
even when garnets are grabs him and
brings him back into the warp uh you
know she's holding it very much like how
a mother holds a kid you know I mean you
could grab a certain beat like this or
something like that but she holds him
pretty much to the chest like very much
like how a mother would and talks to him
very lovingly too so it's like it's not
like oh they hate each other now but
again they're there's definitely that
there's definitely a little bit of
rebelling that's going on and a big
thing is that this ball lands uh in
Stevens uh in their house and it has
these uh these like four or five arms
it's a great design and there's a bunch
of them and Steven gets thrown in the
warp and a bunch of these things are
going with them it turns out there's a
lot of words happening even though they
said nothing will be warping nothing on
earth anyway and they should be the only
ones that you know can see this stuff or
or that can warp and eventually they
follow these things and there's this
character named was a parent dot I think
uh yeah peridot and a wonderful design
my life she has this hand where the
fingers come off and they form these
computer screens and could do all sorts
of cool science wonderful design and is
pretty much it looks like she was just
checking to see if these she's just
fixing these warps pretty much and she
says that has probably been compromised
because I has the sad face sticker from
before and she takes off and the gems
destroy this warp thing says she's never
coming back she can't come back they say
we can't do this again and it just stops
there um so again interesting hmm like
it was this all mean of watching them
more and more it's I'm not saying they
are but they're acting more like
fugitives like they're on the run um cuz
it's because before it's like oh we're
the Guardians and we protect earth and
from the bad things in the galaxy but
everything seems to be me and everything
seems to be bad and usually in those
cases it's not Oh everything is evil and
only these three people are good it's
usually these three people are bad
everything else is good but they're
running away from them so then again we
don't know much about these gems we
don't know much about this universe so
I'm kind of wondering that that would be
a really interesting twist on the whole
thing um or it could be like whatever
blasts Airbender where there's like it's
a world taken over by bad things or
something um and they just escape to who
knows um the fugitive thing would be
more interesting though uh and again I
could be reading too deep into this but
pearl arguing with Steven I mean the
really kind of going at it and again
feels a little bit like a lover's
quarrel but okay that sounds really bad
cuz Stevens a little boy but I don't
think it's quite like that but I think
there is something again where pearl
probably sees a lot of Rose in him and
they they got in arguments or something
like that but it was getting especially
heated uh you know I mean they even say
wow we've never seen this before
you know like between the two of them
like really argue this much um so yeah
just I mean it's it's hard to know what
else to say about it's mostly I mean
it's setup which is fine uh you know the
whole
shows practically set up a lot of its
just the why don't you believe me
because we're us and we have to justify
when you are right you know and the good
feeling or whatever um witching home
works I like him Cal floating in space a
I was right you know there is her that
nice feeling of of justification and
stuff but it's I don't know these
episodes drive me nuts um if the
exposition wasn't there in the build-up
for the next one I probably wouldn't
find it that interesting uh but it is
there and it's and it's really good it's
good build-up where introduces new
character uh you know something hit me
I'm trying to think because we've seen a
couple we've seen a lot weird creatures
and stuff like that and we've seen a few
more gems um I'm realizing like we've
seen any men uh gems which is uh
interesting I'm almost wondering if it's
like or just I mean the gems all seem to
be very much serve like this very
military type group um where it's like
are the men kept out it are there men
maybe there's not been um and maybe like
because when Rose gives birth to Stephen
it's like you know they never done with
a human before and so she becomes the
child you know or half of her it becomes
the child or something like that they
can't both exist so maybe that's is that
part of how they you know can give birth
or how they survive like they keep
getting passed down to different people
or whatever or may there's another way
that regenerate or something so I don't
know it's interesting cuz usually it's
not something that I I think about like
I don't usually watch something and be
like you know uh where's the where's the
women or where's the matter but but it's
like yet we have never seen a male gem
um so but we have seen that many gems
either so I might be jumping to
conclusions um but yeah that was
definitely something I was picking up on
uh outside of that I'm trying to think
it's I mean it's interesting we know
that you know something out there scares
them and there's a good sense of dread
in this show and that's I mean it showed
us a lot of things right but something
they really get is this dread it
like it's all happy-go-lucky and
everything but they're still like
whatever's out there is bad and you
really don't want piss it off because
you will be screwed you know you don't
even want them to know you exist because
you then you'll be screwed uh and I find
that fascinating I'm wondering if one of
the things they don't want you know
people knowing they're on earth or that
they're around or whatever has to deal
with the the one the mere one blank our
name again but uh her going and talking
with somebody you know I wonder if that
connection has to deal with you know
again they just don't want anybody to
know they're there it feels very
fugitive ish but like I said I I don't
know
it'd be an interesting take and that
would sort of explain a little bit more
sore the differences between the gem and
Steven and why they disagree because
Steven thinks they're doing good and
maybe they are maybe they are too knows
um so again interesting set up uh and
it's I both love and hate episodes like
this because then I get really excited I
want to know more as a good show should
but now I'm also like a son of a bitch I
really it's like that's that's not
enough I feel like anymore you know the
last episode was so satisfying in what
they gave and here's these little hints
in this episode and it's a I feel like
it wasn't enough but may the next one
will fill us in even more I can't see
them just after she destroys that warp I
can't seem to just be like okay well
back to a a cat fingers episode or
whatever you know I feel like they would
have to talk about it are you know at
the very least even would um so yeah
it's uh I'm really curious where this
was going it leads to a lot of a lot of
fun questions and you know I'm sure
you've all seen the show whatever but
you know for those who had and you're
watching it with me or doing at the time
I mean that that's kind of fun like what
the N theories could you come up with
this uh
so yeah that's about it uh like I said I
hate the why don't you believe me
episodes but at least it built up to
something really good and still have
that real nice sense of dread that this
show does really surprisingly well so
that's about it I will see you at the
next one later